ま、そこで私は心理学んだんですよ。それ
をやってることに対する精神的価値を
ちゃんと伝えきれてないんではないかと。
だからやっぱり意付け意義付けをいかに
できるかだと。やっぱり理念経営青木サ
の人学
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今日の質問は静かな退職をしている社員が
4割超えというニュースを耳にしてドキッ
としました。うん。うん。
ま、静かな対職というのはキャリアアップやなを目指さず必要最低限の仕事をこなす働き方のことで、ま、実際に退職をするわけではないんですが、退職が決まった従業員のような、ま、精神状態で働くことということなんですが、
このご質問者は、ま、私の会社はインフラ系のため非常に事業は安定しているのですが、社員が意欲的に働いているかというと、そうではないと思います。
私の体感値としては静かな対職をしている
社員は6割以上だと思います。すぐに問題
があるわけではないのですが、せっかく
働くなら意欲的に働いてもらいたいです。
これは経営者のエゴでしょうか?青木社長
のご意見を伺いたいですというご質問です
。
[音楽]
愛があるね、この人。すごいいい経営者だ
と思います。思いやりを感じた。まあ、
正直人はお金のためだけに生きてるわけで
はないし、人生の基盤、経済というもの、
それとやっぱり1/3働くというか、その
時間を費やしてるのが働くということなの
で、まあこの働き、やりがい、これを感じ
てもらえるようにいい職場にしたいという
のは本当に素晴らしい思い合のある経営者
だと思います。で、インフラ系の仕事をし
てるってことはもう安定もしてるし、別に
その社員の式モチュベーションに依存する
必要もないわけだし、ま、そういう中で
そういう風に思ってることに僕は
素晴らしいと今思ってるんですね。でも
これ、ま、大事なポイントはね、社員
国個人のその1人1人に焦点を当てると
言うとこれはね、うーん、なかなか難しい
んです、このことは。じゃあ私はどうし
てるかいつも、ま、人のことは分からない
んで自分ということで答えてしまうんだ
けれども私はどうしてるかって言うと、ま
、そこで私は心理学んだんですよ。やっぱ
人のモチベーション、そのモチベーション
を研究していく中で人は脳の外側の刺激に
対して反応するのではなくて、刺激と反応
の間に選択があるとならばそのより良い
人生を選択していけるような企業文化や
その制度仕組みを整えていくことが大事
だろうなと。公衆体系もインフラ系の仕事
だとなかなかその分配というものも例えば
設備投資から会社としてリスクを取ってる
ものがすごくあるのであの社員にその
まんま分配しにくいと思うんですよ。うち
の場合はなんで税引利益の3割を社員に
分配できてるかって言うと社員の能力
つまりコンサルティングの仕事なので人で
仕事をしているので人に分配をする。だ
から向上ではないからまああとこの建物
って言っても確かに家賃月に払ってますよ
ね。だけどそれはあくまでもこれは別にお
金を生み出してるわけではなくて、必要な
研修の箱ですよね。それからオフィスの
環境だから金を生み出しているのは実質
生み出しているのは人なんですよ。だから
人が生み出しているので才能能力のある
人間が集まる職場を作らなければいけない
。そして人が求めているものは物心両面の
豊かな人生の実現なのでその物心両面豊か
にしてあげられる仕組みを作り、人事制度
を作り、効果制度を作り、若い人から新卒
から採用して基本はね、ま、中途作用も
入ってくるけれども基本は新卒から採用し
ながら育成の過程で事業を大きくしていく
。その人材の採用と育成に非常に力を入れ
ながら社会の求めに応じて努力をしていく
。ま、今のこの会社はとてもインフラ系の
会社っていうことはいい会社だと思います
。社員の生活を守ることはできている。
ただプラスアルファもしあえて言うなら
じゃあ稲森さんという人ね例えば強
フィロソフィーというものをこれあのま
心理学で言うならあ価値フィルターって
いう価値観のところにこの強
フィロソフィーが入ることによって今まで
嫌いだったもの今まで嫌後回しにしていた
ものを優先するとか今まで軽く考えていた
ことを大切にするとか全てそのパラダイム
シフトと言って行動が変わるわけですよ。
だ、その強ラフィロソフィーというものを
入れ、日本航空は同じ社員を相手に
Vジターンしたわけだよね。それは仕事に
対する意味付け、意義付けの能力が非常に
高いんだと思うんだよね。この仕事はどう
いう意味を持っているのか。働くという
ことはどういう意味があるのか。
働くことの意味義。そして我々の仕事は
どんな社会のためになってるのか。
こな間だも実は清掃とかあの組み取りだと
かそういうお仕事をま親の台からやってる
人が僕の研修に来たんですよ。ま、社員の
モチベーションがいまい高くないと。だ
から僕はその人に、ま、アドバイスしたの
はものすごい価値のある仕事だと。
ものすごい価値のある仕事だと。誰かが
やらなければならない仕事ね。お仏の整理
にしても誰かがやらなければならない仕事
。それをやってることに対する
精神的価値をちゃんと伝えきれてないんで
はないかと。ミッションだ。コミッション
のコトってミッションで仕事してんでしょ
、みんな。そこじゃないか。だから
やっぱり意味付け意義付けをいかにできる
かだと思う。だからやっぱり理念経営、
そのインフラのお仕事がどれだけ社会に
とってなくてはならない仕事なのかの
意味付けとやっぱり基本的欲求若い人が
認められるような職場じゃないと若い人が
離職しちゃうんですよ。これからやっぱり
若い人を定着させるためにはあんまり
年取った人に幅聞かしちゃダめなんですよ
。でも確かにね、長く務めてる人でもいや
そのキャリアのある人を尊重することは
すごく大事だよね。長く務めてくださった
わけだから。ただそこがあまりにも幅か
せると若い人が片身狭くなりますよね。
そういうこととか、あとはやっぱり安定
経済の仕組みを考えながらインフラの仕事
をしてるけどやっぱり会社いくつ作っても
構わないんだから子会社作ったり海外進出
とか色々しながら将来性を見せれば
モチベーションも変わるだろうし、ま、
この辺のところ私の、ま、経営者は人生
理念作りから始めなさいを始め、ま、経営
に関する書物も出してますし、またそう
いうプログラムを私は開発しでやってます
ので、ま、一度それこそ私の研修にもね、
まだ受行してない方であればあの
アチュームメントテクノロジーの特別講座
にね、一度来てもらえるとその辺のヒント
もあるんではないかなという風に思います
ね。なんかすごく思いになる経営者だなと
思って、あの、一歩ちょっと踏み込んだ話
をしてしまいました。はい。ま、以上かな
。今日は限られた時間でこのぐらいにし
ときましょうか。はい。
英語じゃない。本当にいい人です。この方
は真心があります。そういう思いを持っ
てることがもう思いやりを感じた。今の私
のコメントの中で人はでも人間ってみんな
自分を中心に考える生き物であることは
間違いないのでその5つの基本的欲求の話
ですよね。健康面、人間関係面、職業名、
地材面、趣味共容面。この5の欲求が
満たされるような企業文化を作って松下
さんや稲森さんのようにやっぱり社員教育
によって会社をインフラ系の仕事でもま
そういうま弱電またあのようなその製造業
でもしっかりと社員のモチベーション高く
経営された経営者もいらっしゃいますので
そういう方々の意味付け意義付けの能と
いうものをちょっと勉強してもらいながら
、あの、取り込まれたらよろしいんでは
ないかなと思います。私はあの、本音本心
本気でもう本当にね、どこ切っても金太め
で私、あの、もっといつでも自分の事論を
述べる。そして事論を述べなくなったら
経営者はもうやめなきゃいけないし、事論
が通用しないような経営はもうやっぱり具
の骨調になってると思うので、本当申し訳
ない。の発言もありますけれども、中小
企業で必要なのはやっぱり社員と共に、お
客様と共に、社会と共に歩む系だと思い
ますので、ま、参考にしていただければ
幸いです。え、是非コメント欄にも
コメントよろしくお願いします。また是非
ね、チャンネル登録まだの方はお願いし
ます。また次回のYouTubeでおめに
帰りましょう。よろしくお願いします。
[音楽]
今回のこの直接的なご質問の方ではないん
ですが、あの、ま、それこそ直近の
ニュースだとパナソニック1万人の自主
退職の希望を募るだとか、ま、大手もそう
いう動きになってきてると思うんですけど
、この全体の4割以上が静かな退職してる
というのはかなりこう中小企業でその状態
だとこの会社インフラ企業なので大丈夫だ
と思うんですけど、そうじゃない企業だと
もうかなり知名的な状態になりかねない。
組織文化というか組織だと思うんですけど、そうなってさってる場合どうする?
運動会でね、静かなね、その退職してる子供っている?いないでしょ。運動会ってみんなアクティブじゃん。なんで?ワイワイワイワイ。だから学芸会とか運動会とか学園祭とかさ、そういう経営をの要素を入れた方がいいよ。
静かな退職っていうことは仕事が嫌いなん
だと思うんだよ。仕事を願望に入れてない
んだと思うんだよな。何なんだろうそれ。
経営者の責任だよ。俺が言わせ。いや、
ぶっちゃけ
それは会社って何?生きがいを感じて世の
ため人のために自分の命を何に使うかって
いうことでしょ。だからやっぱり人の役に
立ってるっていうことがやっぱり生がいな
んだから、そういう実感を持たせる系が
できないからそうなってるんで世の中の
経営者の経営の能力が低くなってんじゃ
ないのだ。松下之助さんの時代はみんな
高之助さんのことが大好きで松下電気に
ロイヤリティを持っていわゆる弱電の世界
弱電ね弱い電気って書く弱電の世界で水道
哲学のようにこの商品電荷製品を世の中に
広めることによって国民の生活の質を
高めるんだということにみんなが燃えて
さらに2万5000点の特約点を豊かにし
てあげよう。そしてその2万5000点の
特約店が地域に密着したすごく決めの
細かいフォローをしてそれがトリプル
ウィン散歩用紙になって松下電気は30万
人以上のグループ正社員になって大成功大
発展したわけじゃん。大変申し訳ないけど
国之助さんの哲学がだんだん薄れてってん
だと思うんだよ。それと、ま、もう1つは
今の1万人の前に何か前に大量に整理した
んですよ。1回また整理なんだよ。で、
その前に整理した時に優秀なエンジニアが
サムソンに行ったり、1番大事な人材の
本当にロイヤリティを持ってる人が松下
電気って人を大事にする会社だったのに
こういうことなのかということで離れ
ちゃった。こっからね、僕は静かな転職
みたいな空気やだけどパナソニックって
すごくやっぱりいい会社なんで報酬的にも
経済的なもので繋がっていたんだと思う。
でもそうなるとモチベーションは低い状態
でそうなると本当にこのお荷物なってくる
で今大体高齢化してきてるじゃん社員全体
がだ実際これ55
歳から60歳までの高い報酬を取っている
人のモチベーションが低くなっている。
これが業績圧迫するんだよね。だそれはね
やっぱりね。うん。誰のせとも言えないん
だけど。うーん。時代の流れ。やっぱり
主力商品それだけ差別化区分化専門化され
た公衆収益を生み出せる
商品がやっぱり作れないっていうことと
松下電気ってでもすごい特許やっぱり
たくさん取ってる会社なんですよ。そう
いう意味では知恵を使って高之助さんは経
を伸ばしてこられたので、ま、私は宇宙で
1番尊敬してる経営者は松下之さんなんで
、まあ9歳から出ち暴行で叩き上げの人な
んで、で、なんで尊敬してるかって、もう
そうシンプルですよ。社員を豊かにした
からです。うん。口先じゃなくてね。うん
。だから小之さんの以降の経営者がみんな
リストラやってるんで、大之助さんも1度
あるんですよ。本当に財閥解体のもう危機
になって財閥して受けてないんだけど戦後
だよね。戦後のあの道乱の中で本当に1度
はその人員整理をせざれなかった時がある
。でもそれ以降はしてないですよ。私は
こんな規模だからお前そんなこと考えなく
て済むんだろうな。その通りです。何も俺
大きくしようと思ってねえもん。うん。だ
からなんだろう。自分は正直今の従業員
270人、300人未満ですけれども、
いい状態を維持しながらクオリティを
ずっと大事にしながら徐々に徐々に年林
経営で少しずつ会社が大きくなってく分に
はいいけれど、急激に大きくしようとも
思ってないし、今経常利益20%ね、
20億の計上利益出してる状態の経営が
できていて、やっぱり3331
税引き利益の3割は社員に分配をし、
そしてその3割分配しつつ集3日に
チャレンジをし、なおかつ年収を800万
を目指してる。平均年収を。俺し高いよ。
その志しは社会に対する心志しも去ること
ながら社員を幸せにしたいという志しなん
で
俺はいい経営者だと思いますよ自分で。
だって社員を幸せにしたいんだから何か
みたいなもんだよな。そんなのよくあの
上場会社でね、ステイクホルダーである
株主にガタガタ言われてさ、俺の友達でさ
、あのスタンダードに上場している日本
ビジネスシステムを巻きた社長ってね、
もうすっごい仲のいい友達でゴルフ中で
までもある。彼はあの社員のために日本で
1番のトラノモンヒルズにさ、社員食堂
持ってんだよ。すごいいい社員食堂で俺昔
五タンダ田の時フェリーチェっていう社員
食堂近くに作ったしな。でも全国フェアに
しようと思うとさ、東京の社員だけが社員
食事あるのはアンフェアじゃないかって
言うんで、うーん、言われりゃそうだなと
思ってやめちゃったんだけどさ。うん。
難しいよね、その辺はね。ま、い、俺は
なんて思われると関係ない。社員を幸せに
する。もうともかくまずそれが社員が
アチーメントを選んでくれた。その選んで
くれた選択を正解にするのが僕の行きざな
んで。うん。僕は奥さんを幸せしますと。
なぜなら無学歴っていうか、無学歴じゃ
ない、無学校歴で家柄もなく北海道の函館
からたった1人青官連絡戦に乗って出てき
た僕を選んでくれた奥さんを幸せにする。
それが男の解消だと。として生まれてきた
2人が家柄のなさやそういうことに追い目
なく自由に羽いていけるような経済力を
持つんだということを心して頑張ってきた
ん
みたいなもんなんかお笑いであるじゃん何
かって本当にだからもうあはやっぱお客様
に対して誠実さを貫くってことだよな。
絶対お客様にはやっぱり誠実さを貫か
なきゃいけない。約束を守る。
オーバートークしない。あとは社会へ納税。今のご質問に対してはそんなことかな。決して負けない経営。
[音楽]
まず経営者自身がお金よりも仕事の内容
そのものに惚れ込んでるかどうかです。